Your penis has not been socialized and it doesn't know how to add
in the left hand light.
Can I have my sex workers,
my right hand light,
my religious leaders.
Okay.
I will say a statement if it is true for you,
walk forward.
If it's not true,
do not step forward.
Stay where you are.
Sex work can have positive effects.
Yeah.
Does sex work and have a positive effect?
Are you serious?
Like in a,
in a society where we're not having conversations about sex,
like of course people are leaning on someone that can guide them and like that
means porn.
That means like that means sex workers.
So many customers come into the club and they're just like,
they just want to talk sometimes.
I remember that.
Yeah.
They want to talk about sex with someone and connect with someone and talk about
their sex life being like,
yeah and be like open about it and like explore maybe like the things that they
can explore with someone else.
A lot of people do look up to us and lean on us for assurance or some kind of
something to hold on to because maybe they are that lonely in life that they
don't have interactions with people.
I literally have a fan that emails me every single holiday and I was like,
oh my God,
this guy is actually someone that's a little bit like emotionally or physically
underdeveloped.
That's amazing that sex work,
my sex work gives him something to look forward to and that's what's sad is
people don't think of people like that that are on the outskirts of society.
They also love sex and they want that interaction as well.
Even with like it within marriages like you need to learn different techniques.
You need to learn like how to role play.
You need to like,
that's why marriages fail because you are not happy,
you're not having sex.
Like sex is a great way to connect.
Okay.
In my own personal experience with porn,
it just tweaks my chemistry man.
Like to where I'll be walking down the street and see someone and be like,
why is that girl taking her shirt off?
Like that's supposed to be what happens now?
Because I'm missing sex education.
Yeah.
Well I don't think so.
For me it's that my mind gets used to a simplicity of it all.
And for me,
sex is available.
I'm married,
I'm married to a great woman that's willing to,
to party and so like it's not for heart and draw.
Is she a party with them?
Um,
and so,
so for me it's not how I got to figure out how to get this.
Like it's,
it's there and that's the only place it's ever been for me.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Maybe it's,
it's like I'm drinking is totally fine for some people,
not an alcoholic.
Maybe I'm the alcoholic with porn.
That just,
it tweaks my mind in a negative way that it makes me go,
man.
I,
I don't want to be thinking about these people I'm encountering like that.
I just want to be able to look at them as humans and instead of like thinking
about people and how they couldn't provide for me.
So I feel,
I feel like
that the extreme frustration is the demonization of porn without actually
offering an actual alternative that kids or adults have of any kind can look
towards first real sexual education.
You can sit here and talk all kinds of massive outpouring and say that it's bad
and it's damaging.
But what is actually,
um,
enriching?
There's nothing.
Yes.
Any sexual behavior is okay with consent.
Yeah.
And let's go ahead and like get out of the way.
Like we're not talking about children,
I'm talking about people that can not have consent or animals because they
cannot give consent.
I have some people that want to do some of the nastiest freakiest things and I'm
not into it.
But being a sex worker,
like I love being able to do that for them.
You know,
like I like to be put in those situations where I'm now like the one that might
be uncomfortable and have to figure out why I'm feeling this way and how I can
come out doing a good job.
I will say,
I'm interested to see you sitting up here.
Why am I up here?
Why are you happy?
I want to walk up because I've counseled couples that are like married for a
long time and sex is a problem.
Like a huge problem.
I do this like inventory sheet,
like oral sex.
Yes,
yes.
No,
no.
And write in it.
And whenever we would go to the,
but play like the guy is like,
no.
Yeah,
I was like,
why?
Cause it's like I'm not,
you know,
whatever.
I'm just like,
Nah.
I mean guys can't even take their own partners sometimes just being like,
I want us.
Yes.
Mess with your job.
Hello.
My standard of sex.
Um,
I feel like I've surrendered to God,
to my understanding of God and the Scriptures as best as I understand them.
And so for me,
if there was consensual,
like you said,
if there's 12 people,
like that's not okay for the standard of life that I have.
Like I said,
I'm going to live by this standard of holiness and righteousness.
That's not a judgment on anyone else.
That's me saying that sex,
even if it was consensual,
I don't think it would be okay if somebody came to my church and said,
hey,
we want to start swinging,
I would say that it's going to destroy marriages man.
And that's it.
High ethic and my church,
no.
Do you have any Antione example of that?
Destroying marriages?
Yeah,
I actually had isn't it counsel people through divorce from affairs?
Is it because of their like religious shame like that they're holding on to
maybe you'd have to ask them specifically.
I don't remember it being shamed,
but um,
adultery,
adultery and affairs is lying.
That's not sad.
That's bad.
That's non-consenting.
That's cheating.
Yeah.
Cause the other person that's being lied to is not consenting to the third party
being a part of that relationship.
That's,
that's cool.
The standard that we,
that I come at it from.
And you guys can say that you disagree with the standard,
but when the standard is that I believe God says this,
sex is for this couple,
this married couple,
then when we step outside of that,
we can,
we can go,
well,
what about this?
What about people that aren't married not deserve sex?
You know what?
No.
According to the Bible,
it's a gift from God.
So now,
um,
that question,
but again,
marriage and the Bible isn't quite literally white people are desperate to get
married and rushing to marriages and getting to bad marriages because they feel
that sex is only sanctified through marriage or whatever okayed and they are
married to whoever and they have whatever kind of sex or they get cheated on.
That's a really sad scenario.
Like I'm not for everybody,
but certain people,
you know,
my hopes is that we finally start living as a nation and don't put Christian
values above human values.
Are we like honestly,
as a human,
as a society,
not philosophically.
Like it doesn't have to be a new religion,
but just philosophically shift our mentality forward from this old book.
There's a lot of assumptions happening right now.
Um,
I resonate so much with this idea of why are we going off of this book?
Heck yeah,
I'm right there with you.
Sometimes I read stuff and I'm like,
holy Moly,
I need to execute that passage.
I need to understand what that means because if I'm going to teach on this,
I better know what the heck I'm talking about.
If they don't understand the culture at the time of the audience that was being
spoken to her written too,
then it can be taken out of context and so there's a lot of study that goes into
it.
But with that,
the statements that you're making just in the past couple of minutes or really
blanket statements of let's just throw out this entire thing because it's
devaluing my work or it's coming against and though I would agree,
if you look at it at face value,
100%
romantic connections make sex better.
Personally.
Some of the best sex I had is like,
I don't know who.
Okay.
I'm so surprised by you too.
Romantic connection.
Make sex better.
Yeah.
That feels very
a universal.
Sure.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I love having a discussion on sex about sex with people that maybe have had not
even,
maybe tons more sex than me cause I've only ever had sex with one person.
Like that's it.
And we,
we've gotten like good at each other,
but that's it.
Wesley,
hang in there bud.
Hang in there man.
Damn.
What's being said right now,
mom?
I think it's beautiful.
And so there has been in my marriage,
um,
transactional sex,
just like,
hey man,
I,
I need to,
I need to have some love right now.
And then there's been like,
we go away for the weekend and there's notes and there's gifts and,
and it's better in that context for me.
So I'm my wife's first,
but I've had a lot of partners and I just,
I dunno,
it just hasn't been a satisfying compared to having it in the context of my
marriage.
Sex is better because it's in the context of like this person that won't leave
me I see is as loyal,
she's committed and we get to do this thing called sex first thing that came to
my mind and now it makes sense why you don't want to watch porn because you've
only had sex with the one person.
So like of course you don't want to watch it because the penis has a mind of its
own.
I want no one word you.
You Watch for it and then you'd look at
your penis has not been socialized like a dog or a child.
I will say I dig it and it doesn't know how to handle that.
You have done that because that is a whole nother level of commitment that I'm
never willing to go down.
You know,
I have had sex with partners where I've lake have literally looked into their
eyes and have like felt like that,
that thing that is talked about,
like that connection,
that bonding of like the souls.
I have cried even while you know having sex.
But to say that it has to be romantic for it to be better,
I think is being overzealous.
I would prohibit my child from doing sex work.
Okay.
As an adult child.
As an adult,
yes.
W W sorry,
can use another word besides prohibit.
I would not be okay with my child doing sex work.
Okay.
Oh God.
My mind was doing the same thing.
Yours was prohibit.
What?
Like,
what's that mean?
Disowned nola wouldn't disown.
Not Love them.
Absolutely not.
Um,
all I would do is just say it's,
it's not what I would want you to go.
That's not what I would want you to do.
It'd be hard for me because of my own view of sex as being a sacred thing and in
my own personal world,
not wanting to be a show for others.
When two people have sex,
there's a soul tie that is created.
Our bodies are,
you know,
emotional,
spiritual,
physical and so is sex.
You know,
it's,
I,
I give people this example.
It's like if you take two pieces of wood and you glue them together and then you
try to pull them apart,
will they come apart?
Yeah.
If you're strong enough,
they'll come apart,
but they're still going to be glue or pieces of wood on both sides.
And that's,
that's what I would explain or kind of define as a soul tie.
There's always a piece of that person with them and that is,
uh,
that is outside of religion.
That is just a belief that I see in the,
in humanity.
To me,
my heart would be sad for my child.
Um,
I would be burdened.
My heart would be burdened for them.
I think the reason why there is so much fear with someone going into the sex
industry,
are they going to get mixed in with the wrong crowd?
Is there going to be drugs?
It's a lot of fear of base.
And my parents told me all the time that I'm changing people's views in that
small town in Texas because now they can see someone who does sex work and as a
porn star and is a family man and this loving and spiritual and yeah,
it makes sense to me why you wouldn't want that.
And I would love some dental too because sex work is real work,
dammit.
And I need to be compensated fairly.
Do you think you want to go down on everybody?
Yeah,
that is a job that is a job.
So like obviously we come from a context where we were like,
we think of like that dark like payments just speeding up like their hose and
things like that.
Just the drugs.
The sex.
Right.
Like to the best of your knowledge,
like what percent of the sex industry is that?
I think we have to then ask the same question,
what percentage of your industry is not truly living their truth and their life
and are they sleeping with women or boys?
Let's take the Catholic Church for example.
Like let's really have this conversation.
I mean,
of course there's people that are bad in any,
in any industry,
in any position.
I wouldn't know that percentage because I don't associate with those kinds of
people regardless of where I'm at it.
Even if I'm out at,
at a bar having drinks,
I'm not over there doing Kiki Kiki and staying up all night,
getting fucking doing,
you know,
math.
Now there's some important stars that might be doing that,
but that's not for me.
Okay,
I have a sexually satisfying life.
Am I having the best 100% sex that I want?
No,
because threesomes aren't happening or gs aren't happening.
Um,
me getting to hook up with the people that I'm fantasizing about at any given
moment isn't happening.
My ideal sex like is this all ends in an orgy.
That's my ideal sex life.
Okay,
that's reality.
So am I living my best a hundred percent sex life?
No,
because I'm truly held back like 70% of the time and I only get to have as much
as is consensual
porn has released me from a lot of my insecurities.
It has opened my eyes.
It is finally made a good looking white man marginalized to see a different
point of view because I used to be terrified to speak up and to have a voice and
to say what it is that I want or need and now I am equipped with knowing how to
do it,
knowing how to approach it and
yeah,
my life is completely happy and I'm having a lot of sex sometimes.
Mostly with myself.
No,
just a little handy.
Handy.
I stepped forward because I feel like,
I mean my,
once again I got it just me and my wife,
but she brings the heat and we have that.
You were just like,
yeah,
I apologize for just like,
she is.
Why she's down and
needed the down as a woman,
I can tell you this,
I can tell you this because we're very modest people.
When she sees this,
she'll be like,
there's half of her that will be like,
uh,
and then there's another half.
She'll be like,
I do.
Yeah,
I stepped over.
You miss it.
That was great.
Hey guys,
this is John for jubilee.
Thanks for watching this video.
Let us know what you think in the comments below and be sure to click subscribe.
Sit over here or over here.
Over here.